THAT HE COD AND
ARRESTED TOHEAD OF THIS WHOLE T
DISTRICT?
CNN'S BRYNN GINGS IS FRONT.
MANHATTAN DISTRICT
BRAG.NEY ALVIN BRAGG COWL AR REO
HE T BLACK PERSON TO FICE.
HE WON A MAJOR TAX FE
BRGHP
ORAST YEAR. THIS S A CA A
D TI>> Reporter: BUT NOW IN JUSS
PROSECUT U.SOF HOLDINGFFICE,  B
BR REMAIM ON THE
POSSIBILITY OF CRIMINACHARGES
HEG I WANT TO DO UMP FOR HISN  .
UNUL OF ANS OR
ANY WAY MPACR IOr: INT
WN AS ESECENTLTOFF HE WOULD, QU
S PET BY NAME ONIAL
MEE SO
WRONGING I
>> INE ALVIN
HIS HEADN AND JUST LOOKING
VERY CAREFULLY ADICALLY
OFFICE. AN WHEN BRAGG'S TIorN ID
GETTING
TO THIINT.ARS WHEN THEY
AR
ENIOR
PROSECUTORS IN HIS OFFICE
RESIGNED LAST YEAR WHEN BRAGALEP
CRIMINAL CHARGESGA>> I THINKWA
THISA PERSONAL ISSUE OR T.ISAGRE
UMP INVESTIGATIOTHISEAE CONTINU
MAJOR CRITICISM ABOUT BEING SOFT
ON CITY.
LAST Y INTERNAL MEMO
TH ONES L OFAMTH WEETY OW YOWERD
ORMER FEDERA
RL RAISED,
ATED, ANS
CURRENT ROLE THRUSTS HIM INT
THE POTIMAINTAINS HE IS A LAWYE
MI NUMOU
JUSTICE ES
IAN
POAN BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Reporter: BUT NO BIGGER HAN H
SO WHAARE THEY DOING TO GEAR
SIBLE INCTAND E
'T KNO LISTEN, ONEF E THINGS
THEY'RE DO LOCAL
R ONLINE, NOW WITH OURTIAY NOT
SO THERE ARE SY ASNEXT
EADY IN PLACE.
E NG CAMERAS BEING PUT UPNTOWN,
SERIEFINGS.
THISET OFFICERS IN
NYPDNIRM F THERE
REAT AGAINST HISE., OF CE, WON'T
TOLERATE
TOK WITH THE